um okay let's see we're hearing from
people that's what we're doing we're
hearing from people around the country
around the world even
why don't we try next um maybe steve
from illinois steve you're on the air
hey dude how are you doing i'm doing
well steve thank you
um i had a quick uh question a couple um
a couple weeks ago maybe maybe more
maybe like a month ago uh john jensacke
said
that the bible administration was
working with facebook to help um
censor the people they believed for
uh telling lies about the vaccine don't
you think that's kind of towing the line
there for government censorship a little
bit kind of authoritarianism
um
no not necessarily i mean listen we we
know that there's about a dozen people
that are the the generators of the
overwhelming majority of the anti-vaxx
content and ultimately what this comes
down to is facebook having and enforcing
terms of service now i know what you're
saying it sounds like what you're saying
is
in practice if the government goes to
facebook and says ban these people
it's kind of the government limiting
their speech that seems to be sort of
the analogy you're making right
well isn't that kind of what they were
doing they were they had their team like
the government team
going to facebook and being like hey
this is who we believe i'm not talking
about like i'm not saying that
vaccine lies should be spread and pain
you're saying it's basically the
government censoring people on facebook
yeah because we i mean again there's
what if i mean again i know you're not
huge what if like the trump
administration was trying to go to
facebook and saying hey we don't think
this is correct like we should look into
banning these people yeah so i think
there's there's some important there's a
couple really important things first of
all
if the trump administration had done
something like this
it wouldn't have been
to prevent
uh empirically invalid claims about
vaccines which lead to death from being
made if it had been the trump
administration that did it and they did
it about something that was all about a
political agenda it wouldn't actually be
the same thing that's the first thing to
understand the second thing is
uh the government pro as far as we know
the government provided information to
facebook about the things that these
individuals were spreading
and it was up to facebook to decide
whether it violates the terms of service
or not now if you want to say when the
government tells you you kind of have to
do it well okay but we don't we don't
actually have proof that that's what
went down so i understand your concern
i've not seen any any evidence
that there has been anything other than
the government providing information to
facebook about the content being put out
and facebook determining is it okay or
not
based on our own terms of service that's
my knowledge about it right now
no yeah i guess i'm just using this
slippery slow theory and then if it's
the other way around like i don't think
it would have been even good for any
kind of administration to kind of go on
that because i mean
yeah but here's the thing when you say
the other way around the problem with
you saying the other way around is it's
not the same for the government to work
with facebook to limit anti-vax
propaganda that's killing people versus
a trump administration to go to facebook
and say
you need to ban anyone who says joe
biden actually won the election like do
we have to be able to distinguish
between those two things
oh i guess i'm just the vaccine is just
the example that's used i'm saying for
future reference if they're doing stuff
that they got that the biden
administration doesn't like that's being
said on moving forward if that happens i
will be right here denouncing it if that
happens
okay no i just wanted to see what your
thoughts were on that yeah no i
understand but but uh unless that i have
no reason to think that that's going to
happen
all right yep all right my friend thank
you very much appreciate the call